el anuncio no ha tranquilizado a los
mercados porque el gobierno británico ha
perdido credibilidad sin embargo la
libre esterlina poco a poco va
recuperando su valor a media jornada
había alcanzado el nivel más alto en los
últimos 10 días y por supuesto este
reversazo tiene un efecto político no
solamente en el gobierno de listra sino
en el futuro de la primera ministra
listas esta semana completará su primer
mes como primera ministra y ya
enfrentará la primera rebelión Tori la
rebelión de su partido figuras
importantes de la colectividad criticado
públicamente esta medida por
insostenible por impopular y porque en
esta coyuntura de la crisis del costo de
vida que está azotando a todos en el
país pero especialmente a quienes tienen
menos recursos los conservadores están
reunidos en su asamblea anual en
Birmingham en el centro de Inglaterra y
ese es el tema por supuesto Entonces los
diputados conservadores le han hecho
saber al gobierno que no iban a esta
medida en el parlamento por ello el
gobierno
ha reversado esa medida Y eso nos
evidencia Daniela lo débil políticamente
que es el gobierno de listras que apenas
comienza